وتبقى معنا من جنين مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري جيفارا كيف يتطور الوضع في شمال
الضفه
الغربيه في هذه الاثناء اعلنت القوى
الوطنيه
والاسلاميه الاضراب الشامل والكامل في
المدينه حدادا على ارواح الشهداء السته
الذين سقطوا فجر هذا اليوم بصاروخ اطلق من
مسيره اسرائيليه بالطبع نحن يتواجد امام
مستشفى جنين الحكومي حيث
يتواجد عدد كبير من اهالي منطقه او حي
مثلث الشهداء وايضا عدد من الاهالي ولكن
اللافت هنا وخلال مقابلاتنا مع من هم في
الداخل فان الش من بين الشهداء اربعه من
اشقاء من عائله عصا عصا من بين النساء
وجدنا عدد من النساء يبكين يعني كانوا في
حاله صعبه جدا لماذا لان احد الشهداء
الاربعه يدعى هزاع كان يفترض ان يكون في
هذه الاثناء تحديدا يدخل الى غرفه
العلاج بسبب امرا مرض الكلى وا بسبب هذا
المرض كان يفترض ان يجد هذه النساء هنا في
الداخل ولكن لم يلحقوه واستغربوا في
البدايه لماذا تاخر عن موع ليكتشفوا بعد
بعد ذلك انه اصبح شهيدا بالطبع كما رايتم
في التقرير الذي عددناه من موقع
الاستشهاد راينا الجثث دخلنا الى
ثلاجه الموتى الشهداء السته اي في حاله
صعبه جدا اشلاء مقطعه متفجره تماما ما كان
قد حدث ان طائره حربيه مسيره اطلقت على
الاقل صاروخ واحد اتجاه هؤلاء الشبان
الذين يبعد كان موقعهم يبعد عن منطقه
الجابريات التي كانت هدف العمليه العسكريه
التي نفذها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد
انتصاف الليل وا مع ذلك تم استهدافهم
الجميع يؤكد بانهم لم يكونوا يحملون اسلحه
تضر امن جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لننتقل الى مشهد اخر غنوه هنا في احد
مداخل مخيم جنين القريب من المستشفى كما
نرى عمليات تجريف متواصله من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لضرب البنى التحتيه
بالكامل كل يوم كل اقتحام هناك عمليات
تجريف بالطبع المزاعم الاسرائيليه هو
القيام بنزع العبوات الناسفه التي يقوم
مقاومون فلسطين ينيون بوضعها في
داخل عمق اكبر في الشوارع ولكن قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيل تحاول اقتحامها يبدو
انها فشلت هذه المره لانه فور دخول قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ووصولها الى منطقه
الجابريات
والهدف والجابري هي المنطقه المطله على
مخيم جنين نعم تسمحي لي فقط ننوه الى هذا
الخبر العاجل نقلا عن الشرطه الاسرائيليه
مقتل مجنده من الوحده الخاصه من حرس
الحدود في الاشتباكات التي شهدتها جنين
فجر اليوم اذا جيفارا مع هذا التطور كيف
تبدو الاجواء وما مواقف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه حيال هذه التطورات الامنيه
وحيال هذه الاقتحامات
اليوميه بالطبع كانت كتيبه جينين قد اكدت
انها قامت بتفجير العديد من العبوات
الناسفه
باليات عسكريه فوق فور اقتحام المخيم
راينا التفجير على الهواء وسحابه الدخان
نتيجه قوه التفجير في هذه الاليات
العسكريه تحديدا من منطقه الجابريات
المطله على المخيم وفجاه صمط تماما اطلاق
النار وكان ذلك دليل واضح على ان هناك
اصابات محققه في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي قام على الفور بدفع تعزيزات عسكريه
الى
داخل المناطق والمحاور العديده في المحيطه
بمخيم جنين وا ايضا فور ذ يعني لم يكن
هناك اصدار اي بيان عسكري من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن
مع بعد ذلك تمت عمليه استهداف الشبان
السته فاكد الاهالي لنا ونشطاء ومقاومين
ان عمليه استهداف الشبان السته كانت
وكانها حاله انتقام وليس لان الشبان شكلوا
اي خطر على قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المصادر الاسرائيليه مع ساعات الصباح
الاولى اكدت ان هناك اربعه جنود اصيبوا
بجراح نتيجه العبوات الناسفه التي تم
تفجيرها في الاليات العسكريه الا
الاسرائيليه ومن شده هذه ال
عبوات اصيب على الاقل جنديان بجراح خطيره
ومع هذا الخبر الجديد فمعناه ان جنين امام
عمليه عسكريه قد تكون اوسع
من ما كان يتوقع في السابق لان
الفلسطينيين يعني اصبحوا يدركون وكان
عمليه اصابه او مقتل اي جندي في عمليه
عسكريه معناه المزيد من القتل
والاعتقالات والمداهمات في صفوفهم خاصه
اننا نتحدث عن جنين نعم كيف توصفين
التعزيزات الامنيه الاسرائيليه الان على
ان كانت قريبه او لازالت داخل جنين هل هي
حجمها هل هي معتاده ام لاحظتي شيء
اخر قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعلى غير
المعتاد انسحبت بالكامل كيات وتعزيزات
عسكريه دون اعطاء اي اشاره ان هناك عمليه
انسحاب فقط انسحب الجنود فوق فور الاعلان
عن استشهاد الشبان السته وتمكن اليات
عسكريه وجرافات من سحب الاليات التي تم
اعطاب ونقلها الى خارج جنين ولكن الكثير
من المقاومين هنا يقولون انه يجب اخذ
الحيطه والحذر لانه قد يكون كما حدث في
كثير من المرات ان يكون ان تكون قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه قد تركت خلفها عدد من الوحدات
الخاصه التي تكون قد تكون مختبئه
ومتخفش سواء في داخل المخيم او في خارجه
ولكن الان نقول انه لا وجود لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بشكل علني وظاهر ولكن
كما هو معروف منذ السابع من اكتوبر
حتى هذا اليوم كل اوصال الضفه الغربيه
مقطعه بالكامل بمعنى ان الوصول الى
جنين من رام الله مثلا الى جنين كان يحتاج
لساعتين الان قد يحتاج لاكثر من خمس ساعات
للوصول من جنين لقراه يحتاج الى ساعتين او
اكثر لان القرى مغلقه بالكامل الطرقات
مغلقه اوصال الضفه الغربيه مقطعه ب الكامل
لا يمكن التواصل على الفلسطينيين ان
يسلكوا طرقا صعبه وعره جدا للتنقل وا
الحركه وايضا في ظل المداهمات والاعتقالات
والاعدامات التي تتم نتحدث عن
332 شهيدا فلسطينيا منذ السابع من اكتوبر
نعم ومنذ بدايه هذا العام نحن في الاسبوع
الاول سقط اكثر من 10 شهداء فبالتالي هناك
ايضا حاله من الرهبه لدى الفلسطينيه
الفلسطينيين في التنقل في الحركه حتى في
المشاركه في مسيره او حتى نشر اي منشور
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عما يحدث في
غزه ولكن ام الشهداء الاربعه ماذا قالت
اليوم لنا عبر شاشه الجزيره قالت ابنائي
الاربعه لا يختلفون عن شهداء غزه اذا هناك
ايضا تواصل مع ما يحدث في غزه من مجازر
وعدوان وما يشبه بجرائم الاباده وفق ما
تؤكده ايضا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
والخارجيه والمطالبه بالتدخل الامريكي لان
براي الرئاسه الفلسطينيه شيء اخير فقط غنو
قبيل وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بان
اسرائيل والاحتلال بكل اجهزته الامنيه
يقوم بتنفيذ حرب اباده في غزه وضم للضفه
الغربيه بالاستيطان بشكل صامت ومن خلال
التهجير القصري ايضا شكرا لك من جنين
مراسله الجزيره جفار
البديري